[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu vou começar contando um pouco da
minha história para que vocês entendam
por que e para que eu faça esse trabalho
eu filha de mãe negra mas foi branco até
o início da minha adolescência não sabia
quem eu era e que papel e ocupava na
sociedade
eu só sabia que as pessoas se
incomodavam muito com o volume do meu
cabelo e isso passou a me incomodar até
que em determinado momento eu decidi
alisar o cabelo eu usava maquiagem dois
tons mais claros que a minha pele e não
tomava sol de forma alguma as pessoas
diziam que eu era uma mulher branca
afinal o meu cabelo não era tão crespo
assim em minha pele é clara
até que em determinado momento eu decidi
parar já decidi parar de alisar o cabelo
mas não foi por uma questão de
empoderamento ou algo do tipo mas sim
porque já não tinha dinheiro para
alimentar a prisão em que eu vivia
eu nunca sofri preconceito pela cor da
minha pele
ao contrário de minha mãe mulher negra
gorda crespa periférica que sempre
esteve à margem de diversos padrões
sociais e eu percebi que o julgamento
era muito grande principalmente pela
estética e eu não entendia por que as
pessoas faziam isso eu tinha um desejo
muito enorme de revolucionar e fazer
justiça é o meu sonho quanto profissão
era ser advogada e aí no ensino médio
tive a oportunidade de entrar num jovem
aprendiz lá na minha cidade no fórum
eu entrei tinha expectativas mas eu
comecei a perceber que a prática era o
oposto de tudo aquilo que eu pensava e
justiça e eu fiquei super desmotivado e
não sabia que rumo ia tomar
eu já era amante das artes eu amava
desenhar mas as pessoas diziam que a
arte não era pra mim que eu ia morrer de
fome
só que eu já tinha decidido não vou
fazer mais direito então eu vou me jogar
no mundo das artes
ainda no jovem aprendiz eu tive a
oportunidade de comprar uma câmera
semiprofissional
aí eu decidi fazer um investimento não
tinha pretensão de ser rica nem famosa
até porque eu não tinha
referência de fotógrafos e aí comecei a
estudar e quando eu vi eu já estava
apaixonada ainda num perto de terminar o
jovem aprendiz aparecer uma oportunidade
de entrar no pré vestibular gratuito
onde esse pré vestibular eram para
jovens de periferia e que o processo
inicial era você se entender com outra
pessoa e o processo final era você
passar no vestibular e aí foi lá que eu
comecei a entender as coisas que eu não
sabia qual era os nomes antes o porquê
eu tentei me padronizar tanto eu comecei
a entender qual é o meu papel na
sociedade qual é o meu lugar de fala
quando os meus privilégios e isso foi
muito importante pra mim onde eu comecei
a pensar nas minhas ideologias também e
aí quando acabou o pré vestibular sem
passar em design apareceu uma outra
oportunidade que foi de fazer um curso
gratuito também para jovens de periferia
de arte tecnologia e aí eu entrei cheia
de expectativas
e foi aí que ela emoção surgiu quando a
artista foi lá que eu comecei a amarrar
as minhas ideias com a arte eu comecei a
usar a arte como forma de denúncia aos
padrões que eu achava que não eram
convencionais que não precisava existir
foi o lugar que eu comecei também a
mostra os meus escritos poéticos e
escreveu os meus projectos fotográficos
e aí eu lembro que eu ia buscar
referências no início da fotografia e na
moda e me questionava cadê os pretos
cada os fotógrafos negros cadê as
histórias que não estão nos livros
e foi aí que eu comecei a pensar sim se
eu não encontro eu crio até porque há
necessidade de falar daquilo que eu
tinha vivido
não só pelas minhas histórias mas pelas
histórias de outras pessoas
pela minha mãe eu precisava falar do
racismo que é velado estruturado que nos
boa cota nos espetáculos desqualifica no
e grega e de tantos outros prado de
tantos outros padrões sociais e me
levantei um outro questionamento também
de como falar de tudo isso foi mostrado
e foi aí que eu comecei a usar a
estética como forma de pagamento
mostrando mulheres reais de corpos reais
tamanhos reais a diversidade das
texturas de cabelo
a diversidade dos tons de pele negra se
mostrando que cada um tem sua beleza que
a gente pode ser a moda a tendência a
capa da revista e que a gente pode ser
periferia sem sangue e agora vou dar
exemplo de alguns trabalhos que eu fiz a
vocês para que vocês consigam visualizar
do que estou falando
esse foi o segundo projeto que eu fiz
fotográfico que teve uma visibilidade
muito grande quando as pessoas começaram
a conhecer o meu trabalho na fotografia
o nome desse projeto se chama gorda
preta eu fiz ele pensando na minha mãe
por ela ser assim eu vi que as pessoas
jogavam muito e eu também ficava muito
chegada porque eu percebia que os termos
gordo e preta é só a água de forma
pejorativa claro às pessoas elas algumas
pessoas são maliciosas mas eu percebia
também que se sua autoestima ela não
está bem
esses termos que atingem muito mais
então eu busquei nas redes sociais
mulheres que se diziam realmente se
afirmavam enquanto gordo e preta
para participar desse projeto não fiz
nenhum tipo de produção de moda com elas
e meu trabalho geralmente fala disso de
realidade do que as pessoas vestem de
como elas querem se ver
acho que por isso tem repercussão tão
grande e aí a gente fez as fotos e foi
um sucesso assim nesse projeto eu também
escuto essa questão da diversidade dos
tons de pele negra essa diversidade do
corpo gordo porque tem esse julgamento
muito grande do que se é gordo do que um
seguro do que é negro do que é negro e
foi um projeto que deu um bom assunto as
pessoas conhecerem quem era ela a emoção
e as minhas ideologias
esse segundo projeto se chama um preto
por dia esse projeto ele surgiu quando
novembro o ano passado foi uma discussão
que eu estava tendo com os amigos ea
gente falava de como a gente era
procurado novembro
lá em salvador em muitos espaços é dito
novembro negro perdeu seu nome novembro
novembro negro porque negro só existe em
novembro ea gente falava de que é negro
negro durante o ano inteiro e
principalmente os recintos e quando fala
dos retintos
a estética ea gente sabe que os negros
retintos são os que mais morrem são os
que estão nas estatísticas
e aí a gente falava também na questão do
protagonismo que a gente queria
protagonismo do ano durante o ano
inteiro falava de quantos trabalhos
surgiram pra gente só no mês de novembro
e da importância que o negro só tem
nesse período
e aí eu falei fazer um projeto eu quero
fazer um projeto de 365 dias mostrando
um preço por dia
só que eu não consegui dar continuidade
do trabalho por disponibilidade das
pessoas mas o projeto durou quase 12
meses
e aí eu levantei o questionamento com as
pessoas assim eu fotografava elas do
jeito que elas queriam ser fotografadas
e perguntava o que era ser negro pra ela
porque isso também é muito particular
cada um é protagonista da sua própria
história e cada um fala por si
e aí esse projeto assim tomou uma
extensão muito grande eu recebia muitas
mensagens e eu vou contar um episódio
vocês eu estava na rua lá no centro de
salvador
andando falando com fone de ouvido não
estava nem ouvi ninguém e para uma
menina e muito assim eufórica veio me
falar de que o quanto esse trabalho é
parte importante para ela quanto mulher
retinta você vê representada e falar de
que aquilo motivava a cada dia eu fazia
foto postava à meia-noite de cada dia
então dava pra ver quem estava à noite
quem é no outro dia pela manhã e ela me
disse que estava lá todas as fotos e que
aquilo alimentava a ela a cada dia que
todos os dias ela leva aquelas fotos e
alimentava a ela e eu fiquei nessa
esperar aquela mensagem né esse feedback
mm e vibrou muito por dentro e assim não
tive nem muito que falar eu vou falar
vocês agora de um outro projecto que se
chama 100 mulheres negras
esse projeto surgiu também através de um
diálogo que eu tenho um amigo lá em
salvador
e a gente tem um trabalho muito parecido
ele é mais voltado para a arte do
audiovisual ea gente falava da questão
do empoderamento eu falo da estética né
a estética como forma de poder a
mas a gente também discutirá sobre as
mulheres que não são essa geração tombo
que revoluciona através da estética mas
que são enquadradas por exemplo a minha
avó é uma mulher super empoderada ela
não conhece o termo mas ela simplesmente
é e eu não discuto com ela sobre o tema
empoderamento e discute com ela sobre o
poder da mente porque o empoderamento
porque simplesmente ela é talvez pra ela
não faça muito sentido do termo
a gente sentia essa necessidade de levar
isso para outras pessoas como uma forma
de discussão também pra gente levar
aquilo que a gente tem e ouvir de outras
pessoas o que elas têm a dizer e aí esse
projeto a gente está buscando
financiamento pra gente fazer o
mapeamento inicialmente em salvador e
rio de janeiro para as mulheres falarem
das suas rotinas de seus cotidianos a
gente discutir esse tema empoderamento
gravando é com fotografia ea partir do
audiovisual ea gente buscou mulheres
também pra gente fazer uma prévia do que
seria essa
e se esse acervo de fotos chegou a gente
fez as fotos conseguimos um primeiro
apoiador para fazer uma exposição em
salvador
a gente fez uma exposição no lugar nada
convencional assim como os meus outros
trabalhos eu falo de uma realidade eu
levo para a realidade que eu falo
até porque a gente sabe que é muito
complicado a esse acesso a determinados
espaços e aí tem uma visibilidade grande
nesse espaço de exposição até aí tudo
bem
quando chegou no passado no final do ano
eu recebi uma proposta de um amigo pra
fazer a exposição dos 100 mulheres
negras numa ceia de natal com os
moradores de rua e no dia 26 o meu
aniversário falei pronto não tem
presente melhor eu vou
peguei as fotos as fotos são bem grandes
assim em molduras de papelão e levei e
aí ele teve a iniciativa muito muito
maravilhosa que foi de levar a arte como
alimento também
além da comida a gente vai ter a arte
então tinha teve exposição fotográfica e
música
e aí eu fui né coloquei a foto lá no
meio do centro na madrugada né não fla e
aí eu comecei a perceber que as pessoas
olhavam ficavam em que é
questionadores e eu ficava fazendo uma
leitura na minha cabeça disso até que
uma pessoa não se conteve e veio falar
comigo é essa exposição é pra gente e aí
naquele momento eu voltei no tempo e
lembrar de quando as pessoas diziam que
a arte não era pra mim e aí comecei a
ficar né toda emocionada com aquilo e eu
falei não é pra vocês sim e aí eu
comecei a perceber também o comentário
das pessoas com as fotos como o sorriso
dela é bonito como a pele dela brilha
como a cor dela bonita com ela é linda
eu digo muito meu trabalho nas redes
sociais e percebo que as os comentários
são muito engessadas assim não
desmerecendo os comentários mas são
muito iguais e perceber se os outros
detalhes faz você sair um pouco da sua
zona de conforto e perceber que as
pessoas necessitam de coisas muito
pequenas ea gente às vezes não vê isso e
aí depois desse baque todo eu pensei que
já tinha terminado mas aí quando eu já
estava retirando as fotos
essa foi uma das últimas a ser retirada
que foram todas as mulheres que foram
fotografadas no dia veio uma das
moradoras de rua e pediu para olhar essa
foto e quando ela estava olhando uma
dessas meninas que estavam aí ela ela me
disse que foi do mesmo orfanato que ela
só que quando ela me disse isso ela me
falou com a esperança não foi com a de d
não sei o que estou fazendo aqui mas foi
com a esperança de que ela podia também
mudar de vida e aí eu fiquei sem saber o
que fazer com que assim eu sobrevivo da
fotografia lá eu tenha sobrevivido a
fotografia em salvador porque como eu
levo minha ideologia muito forte as
pessoas não querem relacionar as minhas
ideologias com o comercial
então eu bato muito de frente para
tentar ter grana pra alimentar e
alimentar né
eu falei vou dizer o que essa garota eu
falei a ela que eu posso eu vou eu vou
voltar aqui para fazer uma foto sua e
vou contar um pouco da sua história na
internet para ver se eu consigo vender
foto não sei se acontece alguma coisa só
que eu voltei ainda não encontrei ela
mas em algum momento a gente vai se
encontrar
e aí eu fico pensando com
são essas coisas que me movem a
continuar no meu processo porque se eu
fosse me apegar só na questão só na
questão financeira
eu não daria continuidade ao trabalho
muitas pessoas não acreditam no meu
trabalho e às vezes eu escuto algumas
coisas ascendi ela esse trabalho que
você faz a perda de tempo é roubada e eu
costumo dizer que esse trabalho que eu
faço da estética como forma de poder
amento não é o único para se falar de
representatividade de combate ao racismo
ou corpo como forma política
mas o mesmo é um dos caminhos para se
começar uma revolução chamada amor
próprio porque se ler no outro se ver no
outro é saber que você não está só e os
opressores precisam saber que estamos
vivos produzindo e saindo das
estatísticas
[Aplausos]